y
[Música]
al menos nueve personas murieron en gaza
por bombardeos israelíes el ejército
afirma que mató a taysir al yabari el
número 2 de la yihad islámica palestina
este ataque ocurre luego de cuatro días
en los que israel bloqueó los accesos a
gaza y arrestó a otro líder del grupo
tenemos reporte desde jerusalén
los presidentes de turquía y rusia se
vuelven a encontrar cara a cara en la
ciudad rusa de sochi reyerta y perdonan
a vivir fútil abordar sus relaciones
comerciales y discuten las guerras en
ucrania y exilio
china reaccionó contra eeuu tras la
visita a taiwán por parte de la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi
beijing detendrá el diálogo con los
altos militares de washington y también
en otros temas como la crisis climática
taiwán denuncia ejercicios militares
chinos en el estrecho que lleva a la
isla
bienvenidos a la actualidad
internacional
aquí en france24 yo soy manejar a calle
gracias por estar con nosotros
iniciamos con noticias de medio oriente
israel bombardeó la franja de gaza y
mató al menos a diez civiles además de
dejar 55 heridos de acuerdo con el
ministerio de salud palestino por su
parte del ejército israelí no habla de
civiles muertos sino de 15 supuestos
terroristas incluyendo a taysir al
yabari el número 2 de la yihad islámica
el portavoz militar agregó que todavía
no han terminado sus operativos y las
facciones palestinas respondieron que
los ataques no quedarán impunes
desde jerusalén nuestro corresponsal
federico cue barberena nos cuenta
las fuerzas israelíes atacaron con jets
y drones armados en la franja de gaza en
una operación bautizada despertar del
alba y que tuvo como objetivo seis
posiciones de la yihad islámica
palestina según el ejército israelí
al menos de 15 terroristas han muerto
entre ellos es decir al llamar y
comandante de la yihad islámica en el
centro del norte de gaza es responsable
de la unidad de lanzamiento de cohetes
contra israel y quien había reemplazado
a baja abudallah está en 2019 luego de
que éste también fuera asesinado por
israel entre las víctimas porque se
trataba de zonas densamente pobladas hay
una niña de cinco años y uno de los
objetivos fue un edificio residencial en
el centro de gaza si adán la sal es el
líder de la yihad islámica él respondió
desde teherán que habrá represalias por
este ataque que no hay líneas rojas ni
lugar a la tregua y que tel aviv puede
ser uno de los objetivos de allí que
israel desplegará la cúpula de hierro el
sistema de defensa antiaéreo en tel aviv
jerusalén y ber sheva el primer ministro
en el ies yair lapid dijo que este
ataque se debe a que los terroristas no
pueden marcar la agenda esto es luego de
cuatro días de bloqueo que habían
impuesto las propias autoridades
israelíes en la zona fronteriza con gaza
después de por por temor a represarías
de la yihad islámica tras el arresto de
basam saadi líder del grupo en
cisjordania el lunes por la noche no es
habitual que israel imponga este tipo de
restricción de movimientos sobre todo
sobre sus ciudadanos en el sur cuando no
está en un conflicto activo y que había
generado también un recrudecimiento de
los cortes de energía y de los del corte
de suministro de productos básicos
difícil de la ayuda humanitaria en gaza
se espera entonces que en las próximas
horas esta situación pueda ir escalando
y que haya alguna respuesta de con
lanzamientos de cohetes desde la franja
hacia israel el presidente turco recep
tayyp erdogán y su homólogo vladimir
putin se reunieron en la ciudad rusa de
sochi se espera que los líderes firmen
un acuerdo para impulsar sus relaciones
comerciales en un momento en el que
moscú busca nuevas alianzas tras las
sanciones de occidente por la invasión a
ucrania los líderes también discuten sus
diferencias en la guerra en siria y en
libia sin embargo cooperan estrechamente
en acuerdos de defensa y de energía y en
este contexto perdonan calificó el
encuentro como fructífero
las reuniones celebradas por nuestras
delegaciones en turquía han sido muy
fructíferas
[Música]
se han discutido varios temas incluidos
la política el comercio y la economía
creo que se abrirá una nueva página para
las relaciones entre turquía y rusia
ahora que finalizamos estas discusiones
es un reunión putin y erdogán también
revisan la implementación del acuerdo de
exportación de granos ucranianos putin
le agradeció a su homólogo turco por la
mediación y también lo elogió por el
proyecto de gasoducto terrestre
afirmando que europa debería estar
agradecida con turquía por el suministro
ininterrumpido de gas ruso hacia el
viejo continente
se ha resuelto un problema relacionado
con el suministro de cereales ucranianos
desde los puertos del mar negro con su
participación directa y con la mediación
de la organización del secretario de las
naciones unidas antonio guterres
los suministros ya han comenzado quiero
agradecerles por esto y el hecho de que
al mismo tiempo se ha tomado una
decisión sobre suministro ininterrumpido
de alimentos y fertilizantes rusos a los
mercados mundiales porque es un problema
para muchos países especialmente para
los países en desarrollo
del recibo de registro a propósito de la
mediación de turquía en el ministerio de
defensa de ese país afirmó tres barcos
más salieron desde los puertos
ucranianos cargados con 58 mil toneladas
de maíz dos buques salieron de la ciudad
ucraniana de giorno mors y uno desde
odessa esto como parte del acuerdo entre
rusia y ucrania es el segundo envío de
granos ucranianos después de que el
primer buque partió era el pasado del
lunes rumbo a líbano
china respondió con ocho medidas contra
eeuu a causa de la visita a taiwán de
nancy pelosi la presidenta de la cámara
de representantes estadounidenses el
gobierno de singh pink decidió frenar la
cooperación que sostiene con la
administración de joe biden en temas
militares y climáticos el jefe de la onu
antonio guterres respondió que los
problemas globales no se pueden resolver
sin la cooperación entre estas dos
potencias andrés granadillo tiene los
detalles china arremete con sanciones
tras la visita de nancy pelosi la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu a la isla las
represalias de beijing contra washington
incluyen la suspensión del diálogo entre
comandantes militares de alto nivel
conversaciones sobre el clima y la
cooperación y la prevención del crimen
transfronterizo
tráfico de drogas y repatriación de
inmigrantes ilegales además emitió
sanciones sobre la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes- y su familia
para el ministro de exteriores chino la
visita de pelosi fue una afrenta contra
su país
pero si la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu pelosi ha hecho
caso omiso de la fuerte oposición de
china y de nuestra repetida comunicación
en realidad es bajo los arreglos
descarados del gobierno de eeuu que
hicieron esta desafortunada visita a la
zona de taiwán de china este viaje ha
impactado seriamente en la soberanía de
china
este jueves china inició ejercicios
militares en el estrecho de formosa que
divide la isla de china continental como
una muestra de poder sobre la isla que
reclama como propia para pelos y las
respuestas chinas son un pretexto para
apoderarse de taiwán
con ese fin como pueden ver los chinos
hicieron sus ataques probablemente
usando nuestra visita como excusa
permítanme terminar diciendo esto los
chinos han tratado de aislar a table bay
sola y taiwán está igual respondió a
china y asegura que defenderá a su
territorio me gustaría subrayar que no
vamos a intensificar los conflictos ni a
provocar disputas sino que defenderemos
firmemente nuestra soberanía y seguridad
nacional y nos mantendremos en la línea
de defensa de la democracia y la
libertad la visita de pelosi revivió un
viejo conflicto sobre la isla que tiene
un gobierno democrático y se considera
independiente de china
en francia crearon un comité de crisis
interministerial para hacer planes de
emergencia ante la sequía histórica que
enfrenta el país y es que según la
agencia meteorológica francesa el mes de
julio ha sido el más seco desde 1959 más
de 100 comunas se encuentran actualmente
sin agua potable y 62 departamentos
están en crisis por la sequía
en francia una ola de calor sin
precedentes se está transformando en una
sequía histórica las terribles
condiciones son evidentes en el canal de
la mancha en el noreste del país que
normalmente se alimenta del cercano lago
llegarme pero la inusual sequía ha
llevado los niveles de agua mínimos
históricos- provocando que el canal se
haya secado por completo se dijo ibm
esto ha sucedido antes pero nunca tan
temprano en el año dependiendo de la
temporada el agua puede subir hasta 50
60 centímetros de altura a veces cuando
es muy lluvioso mucho más así que puedes
ver la diferencia de luís una historia
similar se repite en gran parte del país
por lo que el gobierno francés encendió
las alarmas
la primera ministra elizabeth born
activo un grupo de trabajo de crisis
para coordinar los esfuerzos destinados
a suavizar el golpe de la sequía
histórica la excepcional sequía que
padecemos actualmente está privando de
agua a muchas ciudades y es una tragedia
para nuestros agricultores nuestros
ecosistemas y la biodiversidad esta
sequía es la peor jamás registrada en
nuestro país la situación podría
persistir durante las próximas dos
semanas o agravar y aún más la
declaración se produce después de que se
hayan puesto en marcha restricciones de
agua en casi todos los 96 departamentos
continentales de francia 62 de ellos
están ahora en el nivel más alto de
alerta una clasificación que prohíbe
regar los jardines y la mayoría de los
cultivos el pasado mes de julio fue el
más seco desde 1959 y no habrá tregua
por el momento ya que las temperaturas
superarán los 30 grados la próxima
semana en algunas regiones
el ultraderechista italiano matteo
salvini arremetió contra la migración en
su visita por la isla lampedusa uno de
los centros de llegada de migrantes más
grande de europa el líder del partido
liga está en campaña para ser el próximo
primer ministro de italia en las
elecciones generales anticipadas que se
convocaron para el 25 de septiembre
salvini dijo explícitamente que
lampedusa no puede ser el campo de
refugiados del continente y añadió que
no es un país civilizado el que permita
un campo para 350 migrantes que acoge en
realidad a 1500 personas como ocurrió
esta semana
si los italianos eligen al partido de la
liga la centroderecha eligen volver al
control y la protección de las fronteras
de acoger plenamente a los que huyen de
la guerra que es una minoría de los que
están en italia y volver a la protección
de las fronteras a proteger que el
directo diario varden italia quien tiene
derecho a venir a italia viene en avión
no viene en una barca arriesgando su
vida quien no tiene derecho no llega la
migración también se debate en eeuu hoy
el estado de texas por orden del
gobernador publicano greg abbott comenzó
a enviar a migrantes a la ciudad de
nueva york abbott defiende esto diciendo
que es para que los alcaldes demócratas
y el presidente joe biden se
responsabilicen por sus políticas que
protegen a los migrantes el gobernador
se postula para un tercer mandato en las
elecciones de noviembre además ya ha
enviado a cerca de 6.000 extranjeros a
washington desde abril
el gobierno de nicaragua continúa
silenciando a sus críticos las
autoridades prohibieron que el obispo
rolando álvarez salga de la casa cural
de matagalpa él iba a presidir una misa
con motivo de una cruzada de oración que
realiza la iglesia tras el cierre de
varios medios católicos y denuncias de
hostigamientos
en un nuevo intento de silenciar a sus
críticos el presidente daniel ortega
ordenó a los agentes antidisturbios
impedir al obispo rolando álvarez salir
de la casa cural de matagalpa en el
norte de nicaragua para oficiar una
eucaristía
he querido salir a una catedral a hacer
la brazada la santa misa pero obviamente
las autoridades superiores no me lo han
dado permiso no encontramos aquí seis
sacerdotes del arcos que nos tienen
encerrados en acudí a pisco para que
vamos a permanecer sin irrespetar a la
policía nunca la hemos respetado álvarez
acusa al presidente daniel ortega de
querer una iglesia muda para que no
denuncien las injusticias en el país el
lunes el obispo informó de
hostigamientos por parte de la policía y
denunció el cierre de cinco radios de su
diócesis en matagalpa por supuestas
ilegalidades que él rechaza algo que
alarmó a las organizaciones de derechos
humanos la oficina del alto comisionado
de las naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos de américa central llama al
estado a cesar de inmediato el
hostigamiento y los ataques contra
sacerdotes feligreses y estaciones de
radio y televisión de la iglesia
católica es urgente proteger la
integridad física la libertad religiosa
y la libertad de expresión de todas las
personas la clausura de estos medios se
suma al cierre en junio pasado del canal
de la conferencia episcopal así como de
tve merced y el canal católico sanjosé
de estelí las relaciones entre la
iglesia católica y el gobierno de ortega
se han deteriorado desde 2018 cuando
hubo protestas contra la administración
del mandatario y una posterior represión
por parte del gobierno la isla de pascua
en chile abrió sus puertas a turistas
tras más de dos años de cierre por la
pandemia de kobe 19 unos 230 viajeros
llegaron en el primer vuelo desde
santiago este jueves para poder ingresar
los turistas tendrán que contar con el
esquema de vacunación completo con una
última dosis administrada en los últimos
seis meses y un examen pcr negativo
entre otros requisitos el turismo es una
de las principales fuentes de ingresos
del exótico destino ubicado en el
pacífico y conocido por sus moais las
estatuas monolíticas con forma humana
hasta aquí las noticias sigan conectados
con la señal de france 24
[Música]